19 de los 21 millones de pequineses
están sometiendo esta semana a tres
rondas de tres con el objetivo de
averiguar cuál es el alcance del brote
que fue detectado el viernes había miedo
a que estos tests masivos se hicieran
emerger un altísimo número de contagios
pero hoy se han formado apenas 34 para
un total de 113 son cifras bajas que por
ahora alejan la posibilidad del
confinamiento en la ciudad hay bastante
más tranquilidad hoy que durante el fin
de semana ya no hay compras compulsivas
y las estanterías de los supermercados
han recuperado su esplendor habitual la
rápida reacción de las autoridades de
beijing busca controlar el brote en sus
inicios y así evitar confinamientos tan
largos y dolorosos como el de shanghai
beijing sólo ha necesitado 20 casos para
ordenar los tres masivos cuando se
necesitó más de un millar de casos
diarios la consecuencia es que shanghai
camina y hace a su quinta semana de
encierro y hoy anunciaba otras 48
muertes también hay noticias positivas
hoy es el cuarto día consecutivo en el
que han bajado los contagios en shanghai
las autoridades han anunciado que
relajará restricciones de movimientos en
aquellos distritos donde no se han
registrado contagios